[Música]
você deve estar se perguntando por que
escolhi este tema eu escolhi esse tema
pois existem várias pessoas no brasil
que querem estudar mas alguns promorar
em zonas muito distantes de suas cidades
agora vou falar um pouco sobre o
analfabetismo para vocês entenderem
melhor sobre o tema o que é o
analfabetismo é a condição de quem não
sabe ler e nem escrever
no brasil 7 por cento da população é
analfabeta
isso equivale a 11,5 milhões de pessoas
o novo betinho está mais presente no
norte e no nordeste ita e no nordeste ó
a taxa de analfabetismo é quatro vezes
maior que no sudeste porque ela
favoritismo é tão alto nosso país
são três fatores primeiro escola de
baixa qualidade
segundo trabalho precoce e terceiro
abandono dos estudos
esse é um fato segundo a unesco
vocês sabiam que mais da metade do mundo
têm menos jovens fora da escola que no
brasil e se o brasil continuar nesse
ritmo atual levará mais 200 anos para
atingir a meta do pne plano nacional de
educação
minha proposta é projetar um caminhão
escola para alfabetização de adultos
esse caminho ele iria universalizar o
atendimento para pessoas de 15 anos ou
mais e garantia de acesso à escola para
pessoas que moram em regiões mais
distantes exemplo quilombolas zonas
rurais entre outros
essa é uma prova do caminhão que eu fiz
ele poderia ter computadores carteiras
ele teria um banheiro biblioteca e até
um lugar para relaxar e aqui é uma prova
do meu caminhão vista por cima e aqui é
assim as paredes seria igual a uma
escola comum
muito obrigado pela sua atenção e
hoje
[Música]